anyway do you know what uh do you know
what I found myself missing recently
that I never thought I'd miss what
American portion sizes so okay I want to
hear this story yes so I went to I went
to eat at an Italian restaurant
yesterday and here's the thing about
Japanese portion sizes right obviously
they're smaller than the rest of the
world this feels like an AI generated
conversation is it from trash taste
conversations yes it is it is
let me talk let me just start with the
most AI generated trash taste topic I
could think of it just um so food yeah
just food just food so we've complained
the portrait sizes are too big in
America yeah and now we complain they're
too small here yes okay yes it's not
it's not it's not that it's not that
they're too small so you know you know
how it is when you go to a Japanese
restaurant some Japanese restaurants
give you like good portion slices right
but if it's not Japanese food then they
are way way smaller than what you can
expect in you know other things
especially especially Italian food and
especially especially especially Pizza
like I don't know what it is about
Japanese pizzas but like large size in
Japan is like medium to small size
anywhere else in the world yeah right
yeah so me and Cindy go to this Japanese
restaurant uh and we wanted some pasta
or pizza well I I was a fat ass so I
like I wanted both you know you know you
know that you know that feeling where
you kind of like you kind of want two
dishes at once yeah but they're like two
Mains and I'm like yo Sydney a set of
like ordering starters do you wanna do
you wanna share a pizza with me as a
starter or just have that as a starter
yeah and then we'll have Pastor
afterwards yeah
for my appetite
Yeah so basically
in any other country you could I don't
think I can get away with this because
the pizza would be too big but in Japan
I was like this is a country I can get
away with ordering a pizza as a starter
yeah
um and so the waitress comes over
and uh we order the pizza and she's like
okay waiting for us to get to the other
Mains and then I was and then we go uh
yeah can we order two dishes of the
large size of the pasta because even the
medium size of the pasta is small as
[ __ ] yeah we need to order compared to
America yeah compared to America and
she's like excuse me where where who's
who's the two pastors for and it's like
oh no can we have the pizza as a starter
so you can bring out the pizza before
the mains and there was like
but she was like and she looked at the
piece and she's like but that's not a
starter are you sure you want this and
then we go yeah yeah yeah we're sure
we're sure and then she goes off looking
confused and we see her talking to the
manager she literally talks to her she
talks to her manager and then she like
she has this Panic look on her face
because obviously we're two we're two
foreigners in a in a restaurant that's
full of attack sorry full of Japanese
people she comes back over and she goes
uh uh I know it's mimason and she's like
can I just confirm with you the order
just just so you understand the pastor
by itself the large size is normally
shared between two people and you order
two of them so the the portion sizes
that you ordered would be normally for
around three to four people
we just went yes it is uh we are sure we
understand what we have just ordered
thanks for confirming that we're a bunch
of fat-offs you've got the real match
Stoney ordering experience yeah yeah
yeah so she brings all the pizza and
then she brings over the pasta and me
and Cindy both [ __ ] destroy this
pasta even like even though this is the
large size I'll be honest it didn't
actually fill me up
here's my like in Japan right yeah this
is how you visualize it I feel like when
I order a large pasta I can always pick
up all of the pasta in one hand yeah
it is if I can pick it all up with one
hand you have not given me enough
pasture and I'm always tempted I'm like
I just wanna oh yeah this is what you
think is enough to feed me okay yeah and
and so like we finish it there's not
even like a drop of sauce left on this
bottle right and she comes back over and
she looks at me she looks at her empty
balls and she's she's just like I see
you enjoyed the pasta and I was just
like oh God I feel you're judging eyes
okay I feel them I feel them okay don't
judge me anymore all right she wasn't
even like subtle about it she might as
well just be like so how many days has
it been since you haven't eaten yeah and
then she takes them away and then she
comes back over and she's like would you
like any dessert on top of that I'm like
no okay I'm a fat ass okay you can say
it you can say it okay I get it okay
well fat asses okay okay don't you don't
need to say anymore I don't want dessert
okay [ __ ] son you want some [ __ ]
Desire with that just give me the bill
okay just give me the bill I get it okay
I get it I'll just cry I'll just go home
and cry
no no I was about to say like I feel my
personal experience with eating like
Italian food like pizza or pasta in
Japan is that it's either way too little
or way too much yeah there's no too much
of [ __ ] yeah it's like yeah they're too
much is always [ __ ] yeah no well if it's
the too much they give you like 90 pasta
and 10 sauce so it's like mostly just
raw pasta and there's just like 0.1
coating on each piece of sauce
personally I think the going back to
what you're saying earlier that when you
when you say something in Japan that
isn't the normal system that they have
of like say dining or whatever it's it's
so frustrating in Japan yeah it's like
you can see the error codes in a
debugging menu when you when you say
something where you're like what you
want a main to come out before another
main are you yeah what is on top of
ordering two it's extra large it's like
if you explain this in any European
country maybe they'd be like are you
sure like whatever but like it would get
done right yeah in America okay we get
it sure okay we'll bring it up first but
like in Japan it's like it's like you've
asked if you could like wed their
daughter
the reaction they give you is so so
weird like yeah they need time to think
about it
and again it's that whole thing of like
it's the Panic it's like why are you
panicking
because because in Japan when they train
employees like that it's just like buy
the book yeah and if there's anything
that's an exception into that book then
it's just first reaction immediately
Panic ask the manager it's like bro it's
not that it's not that deep I'm like in
my head I'm just I'm just confused at
what what are they what thoughts are
going through the head that their first
response is oh what the [ __ ] they're
freaking out yeah I don't know why they
think like oh is this allowed in this
establishment like yes it's allowed oh
they think at some point that we're
going to be frustrated or annoyed at
them and it's like no no I if you can't
do it yeah you can't do it yeah I I'm
not gonna throw a fit but like I feel
like I violated some law or I've done
something wrong I think what it is I'm
sorry I didn't I didn't want to cause
trouble I just wanted my pastor before
my pizza I'm so sorry I I'm trying I'm
trying to muster up all of my like
Japanese side to like try and figure out
what the thought process of it is and I
think
big quotations I think what it is is
that they don't want the this idea of
like miscommunication yeah I understand
I understand they're like are you sure
this is what you want because we don't
want you we don't want to you know make
all this [ __ ] we don't want the chef to
go all this through this hardship yeah
bring it out and then you go that's not
what I wanted yeah I understand I can
understand that yeah to the point where
it would
drive you to have a little bit of a
momentary Panic about it I feel like
come on well because I think the blame
is going to be pushed on the waiter
right
I mean maybe they've had some bad
experiences that way too yeah sure I
can't I can't I don't know what they've
lived through right no I don't know
where they've waited yeah did they serve
Papa John or something yeah I don't I
want 30 pizzas it's like so are you sure
about that
and you'll get the slot in Japan right
and this is a question that will happen
if you're eating lunch only lunch
you go to lunch right right you order
again let's just say a pasta you order a
pasture it's always a pasta yeah let's
say uh let's say you order the pasta and
you're you're you know you want to drink
with it you wanna uh berry smoothie or a
coffee whatever you want to know why I
said berries
every single timer and this will happen
in Japan right so if you're coming here
and you don't know they'll ask you yeah
and they'll say it in Japanese obviously
but like do you want the drink before or
after your meal yeah and I've always
found this really odd because in any
other country you don't get it after the
meal that doesn't happen so I've always
I've always been confused by this
concept and the default is after so yeah
I think though it depends on the drink
right if it's a coffee I would
understand why they would ask it right
because it's to a Japanese person
drinking a coffee with a full-on meal is
a bit weird why is that weird yeah in
Japan it is I don't understand this
concept of why I would if I'm ordering a
coffee now and I'm ordering my food now
yeah that should tell you that drinks
always come first right actually I
didn't notice that because I'm like
every time I ordered a coffee I'm like
always I want the coffee first yeah yeah
right every single time you order a
drink anywhere anywhere in the world the
drink always comes first yeah because I
think in Japan the the idea of coffee is
that it's like an after meal drink yeah
kind of like you know like tea or you
know some other you know like uh not not
exactly like refreshing beverages that
go with the meal yeah so I think they
kind of treat it like that and so when
you say I want the coffee before the
meal or during the meal that's kind of
out of the book I I would understand
that for dinner yeah because dinner you
typically but then afterwards they come
after the meal they're like do you want
to teal no no no in Japan it's only in
Japan if you order a coffee during
dinner time they just like stop
panicking
they're like 6 p.m but like this is n't
on this is even on the menu
you've been to they always at the end of
the meal you've had your dessert yeah or
with the dessert order do you want to
see your coffee yeah normal no other
time to ever have a coffee with my yes
so it's only with lunch and then for
some yeah I get it only only happens
with tea and coffee and I'm like just
just give me it I've ordered it now give
me it now if I want another coffee after
I drink my coffee I'll have that but
yeah but that's totally yeah because you
go through coffee like it's nothing I
just but I always tell them as well like
I always say before but then sometimes
there's like this weird confusion where
they're like oh oh okay see because it
makes sense in a cafe setting in Japan
like if you just go to like a regular
Cafe in the morning or at lunch time and
you have a coffee with say you know like
a [ __ ] Panini or something or like a
small sandwich right yeah I always want
the coffee then they'll then they won't
bat a night they'll be like oh yes of
course you want a coffee with that
exactly but I think it's this idea of
having a full-on sit-down meal and
having a coffee with it that's weird for
some reason I drink hot green tea here
with our meals right yeah yeah and like
there's another Italian Society Society
Japanese Society there's another place
that was an Italian place that did lunge
things into the tea and the coffee yeah
and I they always asked they always ask
me do I want it before or after or they
would just bring it out by after default
yeah and I always just thought well
we're eating pasta here give me the
[ __ ] coffee yeah
Italians are crying right now yeah yeah
I noticed there's no way as a as a
foreigner to order pizza not feel like a
[ __ ] fat ass I mean ordering pizza
already you feel like a [ __ ] fat ass
but like in Japan it's the norm to order
pizza to share with everyone yeah but me
I'm like the norm for me is ordering at
least one pizza in Japan just for me and
if I'm feeling spicy I'll order one and
share another one with a mate you know
yeah because like the the pizza for one
person in Japan is like the size of a
large floppy disk like it's barely a
meal yeah the large size that they
recommend for three or four people
that's a medium size I can destroy that
easily easily if you know if I'm feeling
hungry that's I need a [ __ ] large
size pizza all right yeah yeah did you
see that Domino's Pizza went out of
business in Italy did I actually well
they left they left so I presume I mean
well I mean they got chased out they got
chased down they're like you're not a
real Pizza they opened 2015 I think and
then yeah they left damn so uh yeah
apparently you know didn't want uh
Domino's Pizza wow it sucks to have the
option gone right right it sucks is
Olive Garden still around there I don't
have Olive Garden are you kidding me I
think Domino's Pizza was pushing their
luck yeah did I have Pizza Hut there
that's this that's a legit question yeah
yeah I would assume not all right maybe
kayaking track yeah Kai is there any
American pizza joints in Italy I would
assume if they do it'd be like one or
two in the city you know yeah like that
kind of yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
probably be like finding a Panda Express
in China or something like that I don't
what would be what would the equivalent
be yeah I mean but when you think about
it it's like it's such a [ __ ]
backhanded thing to do to go all the way
to like say Rome right right and then be
like [ __ ] man
really want to Domino's right now I I
think I prefer a lot of countries it's
it's kind of banking on the uh a lot of
foreign people and also the ease of it
yeah the familiarity of it yeah and you
know if you order a Domino's Pizza you
know that's just gonna be delivered you
know what I mean yeah you don't have to
call up you can do it online like I
think they Bank a lot of the time on
convenience and ease yeah I mean like
part part of the especially traveling
around I've valued way more now just
having big name brands that I recognize
because of course yeah you know you want
to go out your comfort zone you want to
try to local Cuisine but sometimes you
just want something where you know what
to expect I love that there's a
McDonald's everywhere exactly exactly
when the countries are like yeah we
didn't [ __ ] let McDonald's in I'm
like all right well I mean I would have
liked it but I guess I'm like that's my
capitalist brain that has been trained
to be a slave to Ronald I actually like
going to McDonald's in every country
just it's cool it's one it's one thing
that you go to everywhere you go
brainwashed so well well no because to
me it's like because it's like I know
I've been to enough McDonald's in
different countries now where I know
every McDonald's in every country tastes
different yeah in some regards but it's
still like I could put like a tier list
of like McDonald's of different colors
it still tastes familiar enough that you
can point to something and you're like
okay I kind of know what this is of
course like it's not like going to you
know it's not like going to a restaurant
and ordering something and you're gonna
get like [ __ ] uh chicken heart or
some stuff you know which is a thing
that can happen if you're a tourist here
in Japan you just order something and
you don't know what you're going to get
sometimes I mean I I remember you know
when I went to a McDonald's in France
one time just because I kind of felt
like it and I I felt so invigorating
when I finally ordered
yeah I was like I actually says it
dude they've got mayonnaise on
everything Joey okay they do they put
mayonnaise on everything dude it's a
good it's a good moment when you go to
McDonald's in America and you realize
wow this is the worst one oh it's
absolutely absolutely
I know I know
is why you can never Bank on the home of
something being the best version of it